européenne et on se retrouve ici à
colmar a juste trois semaines après les
élections européennes et cinq mois après
la signature de ce nouveau traité de
l'amitié franco allemande un nouveau
traité mais aussi un appel pour une
nouvelle arme pour une nouvelle europe
pour citer président emmanuel macron ce
n'est pas un hasard évidemment quand on
se retrouve ici à colmar ici on vit le
transfrontalier tous les jours et l'idée
de ce débat aujourd'hui c'est surtout de
vous écouter vous les jeunes c'est vrai
qu'on vous entend de plus en plus ces
derniers temps aux manifestations pour
le climat par exemple ou encore dans
cette vidéo de réseaux qui a fait le
buzz en allemagne vous en avez peut-être
entendu parler et aussi dans la
mobilisation plus forte des jeunes lors
des élections européennes qu'on avait
attendu
voilà donc on est ici pour comprendre ce
qui vous intrigue ce que vous attendez
de l'europe ce que vous attendez de la
coopération franco allemande ce qui vous
fâchent peut-être qu'il vous plaît donc
bref on aimerait savoir ce que vous
pensez
le débat est aussi transmis sur facebook
donc vous les internautes n'hésitez pas
à commenter et à nous envoyer des
questions et à la fin du débat on va
consacrer encore quelques minutes à
répondre
voilà et ceux qui répondent je suis ravi
de vous les présenter
c'est madame klinkert klein carte
je pense en france est mon préféré
brigitte klinkert président du conseil
départemental du haut rhin
amélie 2 montjalin secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères est chargé des
affaires européennes et melrose ministre
délégué aux affaires européennes et
membres du bundestag c'est vous aussi
qui aviez l'idée pour ce départ on m'a
dit donc merci pour cette initiative
voilà et avant de lancer le débat je
laisse le la parole à madame qu'il garde
pour un petit mot d'accueil
merci à vous permettez moi d'accueillir
très chaleureusement madame la ministre
amélie de montchalin monsieur le
ministre
michel roth monsieur le préfet monsieur
le député eric straumann mesdames les
représentantes du président du conseil
régional
chers collègues conseillers
départementaux veut
nombreux monsieur le représentant du
maire de braillards mesdames et
messieurs les représentants de la presse
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
des établissements scolaires et paix
vous chers étudiants chers élèves chers
jeunes puisque c'est avant tout pour
vous que nous sommes là cet après midi
avant toute chose je tiens à remercier
les élèves du collège victor hugo de
colmar qui vient d'interpréter notre
hymne européen
l'hymne à la joie victor hugo qui disait
d'ailleurs que leur réunit tous je crois
que cette phrase prend tout son sens
aujourd'hui avec votre présence
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
c'est un véritable plaisir c'est un
grand honneur pour moi même et pour mes
collègues conseillers départementaux et
puis aussi une profonde émotion que de
vous accueillir ici à colmar dans cette
agora simone veil que nous venons
d'inaugurer ensemble et je vais à cet
instant avoir une pensée pour la famille
de simone veil que nous avions convié
qui nous avait donné son assentiment
pour l'inauguration de ce lieu et qui
regrette de ne pouvoir être des nôtres
aujourd'hui oui simone veil l'incarnent
l'europe c'est plus profondes cicatrices
et aussi ses plus belles réussites
simone veil avait dit que l'europe
l'avait réconcilier avec le 20e siècle
et que nous ne devions pas être de ceux
qui redoutaient l'avenir c'est une
figure puissante et inspirante dont nous
devons poursuivre l'engagement et les
combats il était pour nous évident de
combinés l'inauguration de ce lieu qui
rend hommage à la mémoire du simone veil
femme d'état françaises et européennes
grands témoins du 20e siècle et ce
dialogue de la jeunesse franco allemand
sur l'avenir de l'europe
en effet pour réussir vous chers jeunes
et l'europe
vous avez besoin de racines mais vous
avez aussi besoin d'elle avait
l'héritage de simone veil vos racines
sont solides
humaniste courageuse ambitieuse au sens
le plus noble du terme avec vos idées
avec votre engagement votre énergie et
avec vos espoirs vos ailes seront
puissantes et vous permettront et vous
permettront d'aller jusqu'au bout de vos
rêves
l'avenir vous appartient l'europe vous
appartient à vous d'en faire le terrain
de tous les possibles
je suis européen parce que je suis
alsacien ich bin européenne weill i ls
harbin cette déclaration forte de pierre
pflimlin grand alsacien français et
européen maire de strasbourg capitale
européenne et siège du parlement
européen que nous sommes tous que nous
soutenons tous prend chaque jour un peu
plus son sens en effet si pour beaucoup
l'europe est une affaire étrangères et
bien pour nous haut-rhinois y alsacien
elle est une affaire familière nous la
vivons et nous la construisons au
quotidien avec nos amis allemands et
avec deux amis suisses l'europe nous la
connaissons mieux que quiconque
nous avons connu dans notre cher le prix
du manque d'europe nous connaissons
aujourd'hui dans nos coeurs la chaleur
du plus d'europe lire et nuno rocha
donnera une radio thaïlande verdi verte
dans cette belle europe nous partageant
les valeurs de cette belle europe et
nous vivons au jour du jour cette europe
très concrète à main mais l'europe a
aussi un coeur et je crois pouvoir dire
que le coeur de l'europe
c'est ici dans le rhin supérieur qu'il
bat et je crois pouvoir dire aussi que
le coeur de l'alsace bas pour l'europe
nous avons ensemble la responsabilité et
la chance d'être le laboratoire de
l'europe de demain une europe palpable
facile
concrètes et humaine ce sera encore plus
le cas avec la collectivité européenne
d'alsace qui va voir le jour au 1er
janvier 2021 et dont le coeur des
compétences est le transfrontalier et le
bilinguisme
ce sera encore plus le cas aussi par la
mise en oeuvre concrète du traité d'aix
la chapelle
je ne serai pas plus longue car
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est que vous
que vous les jeunes ayez la parole
n'oubliez jamais que pour tout projet
que pour tout défi est bien le plus
important
au final ce ne sont pas les difficultés
mais c'est l'entousiasme et c'est la
volonté et quand je vous vois
eh bien je suis plein d'espoir alors
j'aimerais vous dire à tous quelque
chose de très simple
merci merci du fond du coeur pour votre
présence d'esprit lichtsteiner et
j'aimerais donc clore par des mots et
des paroles très simple merci merci
d'être présent merci d'être venus
merci de votre investissement en faveur
de l'avenir de l'europe vive le
haut-rhin vive l'alsace vive la france
vive l'amitié franco allemande
et vive l'europe et cela veut dit
deutsche bahn sosie fringe
[Applaudissements]
merci chère madame la présidente pour
ces mots je pense qu'il nous rappelle
qu' effectivement l'europe se construit
au quotidien où il avait dit je crois
qu'elle se conçoit aussi concrètement et
j'espère que dans nos échanges nous
aurons la chance de pouvoir justement
montrer comment la relation franco
allemande
elle construit l'europe elle construit
l'europe que nous voulons chaque jour
renforcée pour que la jeunesse dans
quelques années
voilà réalisation de beaucoup de projets
que nous avons dans nos têtes je suis
très heureux d'être avec michel
ici nous avons commencé notre journée
ensemble à paris pour un événement sur
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
nous sommes maintenant avec vous chers
jeunes et nous allons ce soir ensemble
au luxembourg pour le conseil des
affaires générales qui préparent le
grand conseil européen qui a lieu jeudi
et vendredi avec tous les chefs d'état
donc nous passons une belle journée
franco allemande
ensemble on se voit beaucoup on ne se
voit jamais assez je crois que c'est
parce que la france et l'allemagne ont
su à un moment donné se réunir qu'elles
ont fait avancer l'europe
depuis nous avons été rejoints par de
nombreux autres pays mais que quand nous
fonctionnons bien ensemble en général
l'europe y gagne et donc nous y mettons
beaucoup d'énergie je crois aussi que
cette coopération transfrontalière elle
est le signe de ce que peut être le
projet européen des choses finalement
assez simple assez concrète mais qui
changent la vie qui change les
perspectives d'emploi qui change les
perspectives d'éducation de formation
d'industrie d'innovation bref qui
changent la vie tout court
et c'est parce que il ya des gens comme
vous je fermerai la présidente qui parle
avec des gens qui vous ressemblent de
leur côté la frontière que vous arrivez
à faire avancer cette coopération
transfrontalière en 1963 qu'on le traité
de l'élysée a été signé c'était le
traité de la réconciliation est bien en
2019 quand le traité d'aix la chapelle a
été signé c'était le traité ou sept
l'idée c'est d'avoir un traité de
convergence un traité de rapprochement
non seulement on s'est réconciliés
maintenant peut se rapprocher
alors je crois qu'il est aussi émouvant
d'être ici avec vous sherman à la
présidence parce que je crois que vous
m'avez raconté que votre père grand-père
a été l'un des tout premiers à mettre un
drapeau allemand
sur la place de la mairie de colmar
alors après des années de guerre et de
de haine réciproque et je crois que
c'est parce qu'il ya des gens comme vous
et comme maintenant vous toujours qui
avait fait cet acte courageux de
considérer que nos voisins n'étaient
plus nos ennemis que nous arrivons
chaque jour à progresser je suis
certaine que dans les échanges qu'on va
avoir maintenant on va pouvoir réfléchir
à l'europe de demain qui n'est pas une
europe qui est basée sur la
confrontation mais bien une europe qui
est une robe de progrès en tout cas
c'est pour ça que tous les jours au quai
d'orsay et bien j'essaie de travailler
j'étais avant une élue d'un territoire
qui s'appelle l'essonne qui est aussi
vers vue du ciel mais qui n'a pas assez
pour à ses frontières l'allemagne qui a
d'autres régions françaises
donc je suis très content d'être aussi
avec vous aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
je ne réduis je me réjouis énormément
d'être ici aujourd'hui merci de m'avoir
invité madame klinkert j'ai
effectivement passé la journée avec
amélie ça a été très bien la journée
s'est très bien passé jusqu'ici c'est
vrai qu'en s'était dit qu'il fallait se
rencontrer aujourd'hui donc je me
réjouis que ça se fasse au genre tu es
ici également très je me relis
énormément que cette agora s'appelle des
gens désormais est désormais dédié à
madame simone veil -le qui n'est pas
seulement une française mais vraiment
une européenne et qui nous tient à coeur
également en allemagne et brigitte ce
matin on a parlé d' égalité homme-femme
et c'était la première fois qu'on l'a vu
car ici on met à l'honneur deux grandes
personnalités qui en se sont investis
pour l'europe mais pas seulement des
hommes mais des hommes et des femmes
comme vous madame klinkert mais
également énormément de femmes comme
notamment également amélie et on en a
besoin donc voilà je vais pas
je veux pas aller à l'encontre des
hommes des garçons qui sont ici présents
mais invité également et notamment les
filles soyez attention du fait qu'il que
nous avons besoin de tout le monde des
hommes et des femmes afin de nous
engager en faveur de l'europe
je lui dis parce que je sais très bien
que des hommes ou alors des garçons vont
se dire et ben pourquoi il le dit c'est
un homme lui aussi et pourquoi est ce
qu'ils ne nous épaulent nous également
alors l'égalité hommes femmes
c'est quelque chose qui nous pouvons
tous en profiter on voudrait pas
remplacer la dominance des hommes par la
dominance des femmes
il s'agit vraiment d'une égalité entre
les deux sexes et je suis tout à fait
convaincu que nous aurons tous à gagner
au du fait qu'on va instaurer cette
égalité car l'europe nous pose la
question suivante où souhaitons nous
elle est ensemble et là la question aux
riches ou pauvres originaires d'europe
ou d'un pays étranger
français et allemands ces questions là
ne joue aucun rôle ce qui est important
que nous défendons tous ces valeurs qui
ont pris leurs racines en france grâce à
la révolution française
égalité fraternité égale liberté
voilà des valeurs qui sont aujourd'hui
des valeurs européennes ce qui nous lie
aujourd'hui
mais voilà j'aimerai pas être plus lent
ou car ce parce que je suis venu ici
pour vous écouter pour répondre à vos
questions
pour écouter aussi les points critiques
qui vous tiennent à coeur
mais nous savons tous que en ce moment
en traverse une période un peu difficile
on
hop car nous vivons dans un air
compliqué dans une europe bouleversé car
parfois on craint qu'on pourrait perdre
son identité nationale et prix gîte l'a
très bien dit elle a dit voilà moi je
viens de colmar moi je suis alsacienne
je vais bien d'ici je suis fière d'être
française est tout de même je suis aussi
une européenne
nous portons en nous mêmes des identités
tout à fait différente
nous aimons nos parents n'ont pères nos
mères nos frères et soeurs et on peut
tout à fait de la même façon aimer et à
voir en sort les deux âmes les âmes
nationaux et les aime de l'europe
être français allemands et européens à
la fois il n'y a pas de confrontations
entre elles
on n'est pas plus mal un plus mauvais
allemand
lorsqu'on est un européen convaincu et
voilà dernier point il faut également se
critiquer ou être auto critique pendant
les dernières décennies on a toujours
dit il faut vraiment renforcer l'europe
il faut donner nos compétences
nationales après que celle donc il faut
transférer les compétences pour que les
institutions européennes aient plus de
pouvoir mais ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'il faut faire
puisque tout le monde aura gagné lorsque
nous allons renforcer l'europe
on aura en sera d'autant plus puissant
si des états comme la france allemagne
ou alors la belgique et le luxembourg
quand renforce l'europe et dans tout le
monde va en gagner nous pourrons plus
résoudre les solutions nous mêmes
il faudra s'unir unir nos forces parfois
c'est fatigant mais cela est également
bénéfique à tout le monde et c'est
beaucoup mieux car ici vous voyez les
personnages les photos des personnages
et les portraits de ces personnalités
qui ont vécu d'autres moments de
l'histoire des moments pour les
européens les citoyens des pays d'europe
se sont affrontés sur les champs de
bataille peu importe si on est
aujourd'hui encore en afrique sur
d'autres continents ou même en europe
pardon en dehors de l'europe
il y a encore ses champs de bataille où
les les personnes ça france est
aujourd'hui en europe depuis 70 ans cela
n'existe plus et c'est à vous de vous
investir 1 pour la cause européenne
[Applaudissements]
on va en parler maintenant on va vous
écoutez c'est à vous maintenant de poser
les questions aux ministres donc je
propose que ceux qui ont une question
qui les intrigue lève la main un peu de
motivation peut-être en fait on n'a pas
tous les jours la possibilité de parler
au ministre
là j'avais vu un groupe de deux jeunes
tout à l'heure qui m'avaient dit qu'ils
ont un peu des questions
soyez pas timides moi aussi je peux
commencer mais à part fait via un micro
qui arrive
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour l'écologie
pour pour changer les énergies pour
avoir des énergies renouvelables est ce
cochon on peut te demander de te
présenter rapidement tu te lèves et tu
te présentes
je me présente sur l'élève de
saint-andré collège de colmar 1 2 oui
j'ai 15 ans et je suis un élève de 3e et
aujourd'hui je peux être ici j'ai la
chance de pouvoir être ici avec ma
classe de européenne allemand et je me
pose la question de qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire pour changer les énergies
pour passer à une énergie qui est qui
renouvelables et les laisser tomber les
énergies qui sont fausses il parce que
je pense que c'est vraiment le moment et
on le sait tous avec tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment à cause du climat qui
se réchauffe et de tout ce que cela
entraîne
merci
ce qu'on va faire c'est que déjà on va
le mettre en priorité des cinq
prochaines années au niveau européen je
vous ai dit qu'on allait au luxembourg
avec michel roth tout à l'heure on va
préparer la réunion des chefs d'état de
jeudi vendredi et jeudi et vendredi les
chefs d'état européen des 28 pays vont
se mettre d'accord sur des choses sur
lesquelles ils vont travailler dans les
cinq prochaines années et on a décidé
ensemble de mettre là l'enjeu climatique
parmi ces trois quatre cinq sujets
maximum sur lesquels on pense qu'il ya
vraiment du travail à faire on va écrire
on aimerait que l'on soit soutenue par
d'autres pays aujourd'hui réd 12 pays
sur 28 mais on va y arriver on est maire
écrit que notre objectif c'est d'être
neutre en carbone en 2050 ça veut dire
que tout ce qu'on aura émis de co2 qui
restera d'émissions de co2 en 2050 on
arrivera à l'absorber aussi et que donc
à la fin les plus et les moins ça fra 0
et que donc on arrêtera de mètres du co2
dans l'atmosphère en 2050 ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va aussi investir ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent on veut créer
une banque européenne du climat pour
justement aider toutes les projets on a
besoin de changer une centrale à charbon
une centrale au pétrole
une centrale au gaz en centrale solaire
éolien géothermique
voilà où hydro ou d'hydroélectricité on
va aussi faire de la recherche
beaucoup de recherches et ça aussi c'est
un pro grand projet européen que tous
les chercheurs européens travaillent
ensemble plutôt que d'avoir 27
laboratoires où il cherche par exemple
comment on fait des batteries mc on
essaie d'avoir un grand projet où ils
mettent en commun leurs connaissances
donc c'est une des priorités les cinq
prochaines années c'est quelque chose
sur laquelle la france a fait une
proposition
on a eu neuf pays qui nous ont soutenus
l'allemagne nous a aussi soutenu et donc
on va investir on va rechercher
on va financer des choses nouvelles on
va se fixer des objectifs
on va aussi parler ensemble au niveau de
l'onu au niveau mondial que tous les
européens disent la même chose c'est
fait j'ai vingt-huit pays qui disent la
même chose c'est déjà en soi une bonne
nouvelle
et puis on va aussi encourager les
citoyens les agriculteurs les chefs
d'entreprise des jeunes comme vous pour
le recyclage des déchets pour la
production quotidienne pour les
déplacements à ce que vous puissiez
rangez vos comportements et qu'on vous
accompagne en ce sens donc c'est une
grosse priorité
je pourrais développer beaucoup plus
précisément mais tout ce qu'on fait dans
tout budget européen dans toutes les
actions européennes
le climat est un sujet qu'on regarde et
on n'essaie pas faire des choses qui
vont contre l'objectif à la fois de
biodiversité et de limitation du
changement climatique il est idiot je
pense que l'europe à la tâche
d'encourager donald trump qui a gagné
ces élections avec la maxime suivante et
il a dit la protection du climat va tuer
va faire disparaître des jobs il est
difficile de réaliser les objectifs et
en france comme en allemagne nous avons
déjà eu de mauvaises expériences 40% en
allemagne sont issues de sources
d'énergie renouvelable et jusqu'en 2038
nous voulons complètement arrêter les
centrales de charbon et il est vrai
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
directement concernés qui ont peur de
perdre leur poste
il faut leur expliquer que le travail
l'économie
un état qui soutient ses citoyens et
d'autre part la protection du climat et
ben qui vont main dans la main sinon en
asie en afrique
ils ne vont pas suivre la voie que nous
avons entamé il nous faut ne pas mettre
l'accent sur le fait qu'il nous faut
avoir moins de mobilité
moins de prestations et cetera si ce
sont 100 nos arguments et ben on va
jamais gagné ce débat dans ce cas là ce
seront des populistes ce seront les
monteurs qui vont eux gagné les
élections et c'est pour ça que c'est un
défi tellement dur à relever est
tellement compliqué nous avons décidé
quel avenir en europe nous voulons
investir 40 % des dépenses dans la
protection du climat
partout où il y à des alternatives nous
voulons renoncer entièrement en
plastique
lorsqu'il existe des alternatives nous
allons interdire carrément le plastique
ce sont des petits pains mais des pas
incontournable et si j'ai bien compris
le message des jeunes leur des frais des
faits fioutch g compte je pense qu'on
doit être encore plus courageux mais
pour cela j'ai besoin nous avons besoin
de vous parce que dans chaque quartier
ou j'entame ces mesures et ben j'ai
toujours une initiative qui est contre
les infrastructures nécessaires contre
les mesures à prendre et vous avez tout
le temps cette polémique donc il faut
qu'on puisse maintenant davantage mettre
en avant ce que nous soutenons y non
plus les choses donc auquel nous sommes
contre la presse entre al nucléaire de
fessenheim est l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés pour le département du haut
rhin c'est de faire de notre territoire
le premier territoire alimenté
uniquement en énergies renouvelables et
décarbonées
ça veut dire c'est un enjeu énorme mais
si on ne se fixe pas des zombies des
objectifs ambitieux
ça n'est pas la peine du mois je
l'estiment de faire de la politique
l'idée c'est de mettre en place et en
appel à projets a été lancé déjà par
l'état du photovoltaïque
l'idée c'est de réfléchir à d'autres
installations dans le domaine de la
méthanisation aussi des énergies
nouvelles mais qui prennent de l'ampleur
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène notamment
pour pour les déplacements voilà donc
qu'il y à il ya une véritable ambition
qui est affiché et j'espère bien qu'on
va arriver à au bout de ce défi et puis
comme cela vient d'être dit aussi par
par mickaël d habitude nouvelles à
prendre et par chacune et chacun d'entre
nous mais aussi par les collectivités
et là nous avons lancé depuis l'an
dernier un plan daide pour la rénovation
thermique et énergétique des bâtiments
de la sortie du nucléaire en allemagne
serait pas aussi un modèle pour la
france finalement alors je sais oui
le président de la république a bien
annoncé que nous réduirons la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergétique
pour redescendre à 50% en 2035
il faut savoir que l'énergie nucléaire
ne produit aucun co2 la fumée qui
s'échappe d'une centrale nucléaire
c'est de la vapeur d'eau c'est pas de la
pollution le problème du nucléaire c'est
la gestion des déchets parce qu'on sait
que la radioactivité des déchets eh ben
elle et va durer pendant des centaines
de milliers d'années et que donc il faut
qu'on s'en protège parce qu'elle est
dangereuse mais je me tiens à dire ça
quand vous voyez une centrale nucléaire
ça ne contribue pas au réchauffement
climatique
sacré d'autres risques sacré d'autres
enjeux c'est pas une énergie
renouvelable au sens où effectivement il
ya des déchets qu'il faut qu'on donc il
faut qu'on s'occupe et ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on prenne une décision
difficile mais il faut avoir en tête que
c'est ce qui permet aujourd'hui à la
france d'être pays qui produit le moins
de co2 de tous les pays du monde
de tous les pays du monde pour produire
son électricité
donc ça des inconvénients mais ça aussi
ne le permet d'avoir une économie qui
aujourd'hui émet peu de co2 par rapport
à d'autres autre enjeu la livre la
feuille de route du gouvernement c'est
de passer d'à peu près 75 % d'énergie
produite par le nucléaire à 50% en 2035
et que toute cette énergie qui va
falloir produire autrement elle soit
100% renouvelable
on va fermer nos centrales à charbon
d'ici 2022 tout
donc il n'y aura plus au travail charbon
en france il restera quelques centrales
à gaz qu'on allume uniquement les jours
où il ya des grosses demandé qu' il faut
un petit à point mais ça on y travaille
pour que d'ici 2030 2035
on soit dans l'incapacité de produire
que de l'énergie qui ne produit pas de
co2 donc bien solaire ou bien il dort
ouvre des éoliennes ou bien géothermique
par la biomasse aussi hydroélectricité
et donc effectivement du nucléaire
et c'est un choix qu'on fait de
considérer que ça nous permet d'avoir
une énergie assez peu cher même s'il
faut qu'on continue d'investir et une
énergie qui a fait que je répète notre
pays est le pays qui émet le moins de
co2 pour chaque kilo watt donc que
chaque et pour toutes les crises iteco
vraiment notre pays ça apporte des
risques c'est pour ça que la fessenheim
la centrale étant aujourd'hui un peu
anciennes on a ou bien il aurait fallu
investir massivement
ou bien il faut la fermer il va y avoir
un plan pour la démanteler retirer la
radioactivité et on en a parlé avec
madame la présidente et j'en ai aussi
parlé aujourd'hui avec michel roth
il faut qu'on ait un projet
effectivement pour que ce lieu ne veut
pas une friche que les emplois qui sont
autour ne soit pas perdu mais qu'on
invente quelque chose de nouveau que ce
soit aussi un moment où la transition
vous allez on parle beaucoup de
transition transition ça veut dire
renoncer à des choses et en créer de
nouvelles
mais ici effectivement il ya des emplois
qui vont disparaître
il faut qu'on soit capable de créer les
nouveaux on produisait l'énergie
nucléaire il faut que dément produisent
une autre énergie et il faut qu'on
change le mode de vie donc c'est ça que
nos états que les que les états que les
acteurs locaux que les tous les acteurs
politiques essayent d'organiser pour que
bien les jeunes qui se posent des
questions comme vous chers jeunes de 3e
vous puissiez avoir demain quand vous
aurez 30 ans 45 ans 60 ans un monde qui
sera vivable et sera un monde où vous
aurez envie vous même et bien de vous
investir et travailler d'autres
questions
avec la classe européenne allemand et je
voulais savoir où en était la politique
commune européenne est aussi l'économie
comme une europe commune européenne la
politique commune ou même au niveau de
l'union européenne
ces questions précis pour quelqu'un
parce que des politiques communes y en a
plein
comment la les accords entre les
politiques comme pour s'accorder
ensemble au niveau des décisions
communes
je vais essayer de donner quelques
indications
on fait beaucoup de politique ensemble
on fait une politique de la recherche on
fait une politique degré de
l'agriculture ont fait une politique des
infrastructures des routes des ponts des
autos des des systèmes qui nous aide à
avoir de l'électricité les réseaux tout
ce qu'ils transportent les lots les le
pétrole fin bref tout ce qui nous
alimente on a une politique industrielle
commune pour avoir des entreprises qui
travaillent ensemble on a une politique
de la jeunesse pour que vous puissiez
quand vous serez un peu plus âgés faire
des échanges avec erasmus
on a une politique des universités donc
on a plein de politique commune on a
aussi une politique extérieure commune
ont fait de la diplomatie ensemble bref
dans beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines tous les mois les ministres des
différents pays se réunissent et ils
mettent en commun la politique des
transports la politique des autres
industries la politique de la jeunesse
la politique de l'éducation la politique
doit être extérieur donc la diplomatie
nous on se rencontre aussi tous les mois
et on essaie de faire avancer nos
politiques est-ce que c'est facile de se
mettre d'accord
pas toujours est-ce qu'on est obligé de
tous d'accord pas toujours il est
politique on a besoin de la majorité et
les politiques on a besoin de
l'unanimité
et c'est vrai que se mette d'accord à
l'unanimité à 28 pays c'est difficile
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes histoires
parce qu'on n'a pas le même
développement économique parce qu'on n'a
pas les mêmes besoins
parce qu'on n'a pas la même culture mais
c'est ça mon métier et j'allais dire et
celui de michel c'est que voilà on est
avec vous aujourd'hui souvent en voyage
beaucoup
parce que
1 et l'autre on va voir tous les pays
qui peut-être sont pas totalement
d'accord avec nous et on essaie de voir
comment on peut les aider aussi à
trouver un intérêt dans ce qu'on propose
et donc moi si je résume où en est la
politique commune et l'économie
européenne et beaucoup de choses qu'on
veut faire ensemble pour l'industrie
pour la recherche pour créer des grandes
entreprises européennes pour innover
ensemble pour aussi payer pour que les
gens qu'ils soient payés pour le travail
pendant une politique sociale commune
pour qu'on ait les mêmes droits on est
en train d'avancer faire avancer tout ça
mais la principale difficulté c'est que
vous qu'on se mettre d'accord ou à la
majorité ou à l'unanimité et donc le
métier des diplomates
eh bien ça va les chercher des
équilibres ou des accords au tout le
monde y gagne
on en trouve ça nous prend du temps et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce métier et
d'autre chose politique pro européenne
ue l'yonne il est vrai que dans la
politique économique l'europe joue un
rôle central
parce que il y à l'espoir que la
prospérité soit l'âme de l'europe le
marché intérieur c'est de ne pas avoir
de frontières par rapport au capital au
prestations pour les marchandises ni
pour vous pour les employés nous nous
rendons compte que il y a le besoin
d'établir des règles communes pour
l'europe et qu' il y à beaucoup d'hommes
politiques et beaucoup de citoyens qui
trouvent que c'est difficile parce que
pour avoir des règles communes il faut
ici ou là renoncer à des règles qui
existait depuis longtemps en allemagne
et en france
il est vrai que en allemagne nous avons
eu beaucoup de problèmes parce que le
diplôme
du masters existants en allemagne a été
changé et la même chose vaut pour les
ramoneurs qui eux aussi ont dû là on a
dû changer les règles de leur métier et
c'est vrai qu'ici ou là on arrive donc
de vrais obstacles et les personnes se
demandent pourquoi l'union européenne
doit régler ce genre de questions nous
avons donc cette économie commune
cette politique de l'économie commune
qui se heurte ici ou là a des problèmes
et on a des déséquilibres et il y à ce
gap entre les riches et les pauvres qui
ne cesse de s'accroître et il nous faut
donc non seulement une politique
économique mais aussi sociale
il y à une initiative issue de la france
basé sur le principe d'avoir le même
salaire pour le même travail et cela
veut dire que l'on exploite pain les
travailleurs nous l'avons pas encore
vraiment mis en oeuvre je crois que
c'est surtout dans les régions
transfrontalières qu' il y à pas mal de
conflits entre la france et l'allemagne
parce qu'il y à des obstacles qui sont
ressenties comme beaucoup plus beaucoup
trop élevé du côté des entreprises
apparemment il ya pas mal de problèmes
en tout cas c'est mon impression mais
l'idée qu'il ya derrière elle est
primordiale et je suis très
reconnaissant au président de la
république il n'est pas social démocrate
comme moi mais il promeut fortement
cette idée d'une europe sociale et
amélie vient de le dire
l'europe est un marché intérieur une
économie commune et qu'on ne veut pas
qu'on ne souhaite pas avoir une poule
éthique économique sans une économie
politique sociale les traités de
maastricht
[Musique]
fondée par colin et un mitterrand on
laissé beaucoup trop de différence en ce
qui le concerne l'imposition les
standards sociaux etc c'est quelque
chose qui ne pourrait pas marcher à
l'avenir il est vrai que nous allons
l'avenir avoir cette tâche a relevé de
regagner la confiance des citoyens mais
aussi des entreprises et des
travailleurs d'autres questions il ya
une expression qui dit que si la
première question difficile la deuxième
est beaucoup plus simple on va passer
directement la deuxième question bonjour
je m'appelle
deux laboratoires en recherche spatiale
c'est vraiment dans la création de
biosphère d'exo atmosphère est-ce que
c'est dans vos ambitions pour la
recherche commune en europe la recherche
spatiale
c'est un des domaines où l'europe fait
beaucoup de choses ensemble vous avez
l'agencé spatiale européenne
vous avez en france le cnes vous avez en
allemagne aussi beaucoup chercheurs oui
on pense que la recherche qui qui vient
en tout cas la recherche spatiale
d'une certaine manière nous aide à
comprendre beaucoup de choses sur terre
donc est-ce qu'on veut créer des exo à
des exo atmosphère pouvoir vivre sur
mars ou ailleurs je crois que c'est même
en france on a beaucoup de gens qui
cherchent là dessus la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on travaille aussi avec la nasa
et que c'est plus l'heure de la guerre
froide
donc il ya aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
programmes de recherche qu'on fait
ensemble et moi je viens d'un territoire
donc en essonne où il ya des grands
centres de recherche sur le plateau de
saclay et où je peux vous dire qu'il ya
des chercheurs qui travaillent sur ces
sujets là et la bonne nouvelle s'il
travaille aussi avec les chercheurs des
autres pays européens est souvent
d'ailleurs ils travaillent des
chercheurs américains parce qu'on pense
que c'est un des défis comme la lutte
contre le cancer comme on a parlé la
lutte pour trouver des nouvelles
énergies comme bien sûr beaucoup
d'autres sujets de recherche sur notre
environnement qui nécessite non
seulement que les pays s'engagent mais
surtout qui partagent des résultats
parce que ça nous intéresse tous qu'on
soit français brésiliens américains
chinois ou indien
écoute tu as très bien qu'amélie soit là
puisque moi j'avoue j'ai aucune idée de
la recherche spatiale
mais je sais que nous disposons d'une
d'une agence qui est basée à en hesse à
darmstadt qui est dédié à cette
recherche spatiale et qui essayent de
de travailler dans ce domaine afin que
les grands acteurs comme les états unis
n'en croise pas tous le terrain dans ce
domaine question c'est pour en revenir à
la question de lizac par rapport à la
relation comme une relation économique
c'était pour savoir si avec le brésil
qui se déroule en ce moment la sortie de
de l'angleterre du royaume uni de
l'union européenne ça ralentissait vous
vos autres projets pour l'avenir
alors tout d'abord c'est vrai que la
pole moment nous vivons vraiment un
désastre horrible car ceux qui ont
promis aux gens que tout sera mieux
après la sortie de l'union européenne
sont pas au rendez vous peuvent pas
tenir leurs promesses en a tant promis
aux britanniques
tout cet argent qui est paul non encore
versées aux à l'union européenne ne sera
pas le futur investi directement dans la
grande bretagne mais ils peuvent pas
tenir ses promesses donc là aussi en a
encore une fois menti au peuple
il est très très compliqué de sortir
comme ça de l'union européenne on ne
résout pas aucun problème
il y a tant d'autres qui sont créées je
sais qu'en france mais également en
allemagne et moi personnellement aussi
jeu je pense parfois que alors
finalement ils sont sortis puisque de
toute façon c'était énervant de
travailler avec eux ces prix thani qu'il
valait à chaque où il voulait à chaque
fois avoir une solution prix coller sur
mesure un britannique
donc les britanniques ont été
compliquées et pourtant nous les
allemands parfois on peut paraître
difficile aussi aux yeux des français et
moi j'aurais préféré de travailler de
continuer à travailler avec les
britanniques
car ils sont un partenaire important à
l'avenir il va falloir payer 10 à 13
millions d'euros de plus car il faudra
compenser ce qui sera plus payée par la
compagne alors soit il faut compenser
soit il faut réduire les dépenses dans
la pac dans la politique agricole
commune dans d'autres domaines et
erasmus plus mobilité etc ça on pourrait
le faire réduire les dépenses ou alors
commencer et payer plus et bon la
question qui se pose qui va payer plus
et où est ce que ça sera à verser donc
ça deviendra beaucoup plus difficile
sans la prendre peu terne y seul espoir
seul bémol espoirs il ya ceux en
allemagne ou en france qui disent que à
tous sera au mieux après on va protéger
notre pays en sortant de l'union
européenne alors ces voix là sont
devenus plus timides car on voit que
c'est quand même compliqué ce qui est
sûr c'est que ça a beaucoup surpris
quand le référendum a eu lieu ce matin
la première chose que ça a fait c'est
que ça occuper beaucoup de monde de
réfléchir à comment on pouvait se
séparer d'un pays jusqu'à maintenant
l'histoire de l'union européenne
s'étaient l'histoire où on s'ajoutaient
les uns aux autres c'était une addition
c'était pas une soustraction
effectivement il ya eu beaucoup de monde
beaucoup d'intelligence beaucoup de
temps passé à réfléchir à organiser le
plus de manière à plusieurs données
possible la sortie en tout cas trouvé un
accord pour que ça puisse ça puisse bien
se passer
on voit que c'est très difficile pour
les britanniques de réaliser et de
vouloir vraiment se lancer dans cette
sortie tout est sur la table aujourd'hui
est donc tout ce qui dure en fait c'est
que c'est très compliqué politiquement
c'est très compliqué socialement c'est
très compliqué tout court de se dire bon
on comprend maintenant les conséquences
de ce que ça veut dire de sortir
est-ce que ça ralentit notre travail ce
qui est certain c'est que une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a dit que ces
négociations n'avaient pas duré 15 ans
mais allait durer deux ans pour
lesquelles on a mis une date limite qui
a été repoussée effectivement du mois de
mars mois d'octobre c'est à dire on a
besoin aussi de pouvoir nous mêmes en
europe fonctionner sans avoir cette
incertitude michel rault de parler du
budget
c'est une énorme incertitude est ce que
les britanniques participent à nos
politiques et skizomeuh non sur les
bénéficiaires ce qui participe lui mais
ce cossu du coup il faut qu'on fasse
sans eux c'est une vraie question ce
qu'on essaie d'organiser ces qu' on
puisse travailler sur les priorités dont
a parlé on a parlé du climat on a parlé
d'europe sociale
on a parlé d'europe de la défense
on veut pour de reparler de nos
frontières comment s'organise aussi sur
les nouveaux défis face aux états unis à
la chine notamment dans l'industrie la
concurrence on a besoin de s'occuper de
ça est-ce que nous ça nous ralentit
je crois pas que ça nous ralentissent
est ce que ça nous préoccupe
ça nous préoccupe ça c'est clair est ce
qu'on a nous là tous les deux ou avec
d'autres la clé la clé aujourd'hui elle
est à londres
c'est une décision des britanniques il
faut que sur les britanniques qui
apporte la réponse qui veulent apporter
nous européens je crois qu'on a mis
beaucoup de choses sur la table
on a proposé un accord c'était le fruit
de beaucoup de travail
ça nous préoccupe plus que ça nous
ralentit je pense c'est vrai que j'avais
pas très bien compris votre question
donc je vais tout de même essayer de
donner vous donner une réponse concrète
car c'est vrai que alors moi je pense ça
nous ralentit énormément puisque ça nous
a coûté énormément de temps au sein de
notre conseil le président se négocie et
une fois par mois on se rencontrer à
chaque fois pendant des heures il
fallait parler tout d'abord du proxy et
c'était vraiment fâché et cela dure
depuis deux ans maintenant et donc nous
n'avons pas pu atteindre tout ce qu'on a
voulu atteindre et j'aurais bien aimé de
parler d'autres sujets et voilà ça m'a
énervé très honnêtement moi je voudrais
une question d'une fille a très bien en
premier rang
je m'appelle je m'appelle louise et je
suis en terminale au lycée jeanne d'arc
de mulhouse j'avais une question on
évoquait la précédemment le budget de
l'union européenne
mais on sait que le budget de l'union
européenne il représente à peu près 1%
du pib total européen
est-ce que c'est pas un problème
justement cette faiblesse la faiblesse
de ce budget par rapport à toutes les
ambitions vous semblez avoir c'est un
sujet où historiquement la france et
l'allemagne n'ont pas toujours la même
vue donc comme ça vous allez voir la
différence de tonalité
ce budget c'est aussi des impôts que les
français les allemands les italiens les
espagnols eux payent et au luxe aille
dans leur budget national ça va dans le
budget européen donc et pas d'argent
magique et donc si on dit augmenter le
budget européen il faut que ce soit
financée par quelqu'un comme on sait
bien que les français les allemands les
italiens les espagnols ont pas envie de
payer des impôts et des impôts et des
impôts ils ont bien raison il faut qu'on
soit efficace et donc ce à quoi on
travaille c'est qu'effectivement on
puisse d'abord réformer et les
politiques qu'il faut qu'on rentre
peut-être plus efficace plus efficiente
sur le budget de l'agriculture par
exemple on en a parlé on aimerait qu'il
ait une grande partie de ce budget qui
bien sûr est les agriculteurs à
poursuivre leur métier mais aussi à se
transformer à le rendre plus écologique
une certaine manière et des nouvelles
politiques à financer dans la défense
dans les frontières dans l'innovation
dans cette europe sociale et donc ce
qu'on se dit c'est que oui il faut que
l'argent qui viennent dé ceux qui payent
les impôts on aimerait aussi créer des
ressources en fait des moyens de
financier de l'union européenne sans
passer par la poche de vos parents ou de
vous quand vous travaillerez on est en
train de réfléchir à une ressource qui
soit basée sur le plastique est que le
plastique les recycler ils vous donnent
des bons points à 10 mètres donc vous
payez pas en revanche le plastique ans
n'est pas recyclé vous êtes obligés de
payer le budget européen et ça fait
comme ça
une sorte de contribution qui ne dépend
pas de savoir si vous êtes un italien
espagnol ou un bras ça dépend est-ce que
autour de vous votre système de déchets
ça tombe bien c'est les élus locaux qui
on travaille là dessus
est-ce qu'il fonctionnait bien ou pas
s'il fonctionne bien que ça aussi bien
plastique très bien
s'il fonctionne moins bien eh bien on
demandera aux uns et aux autres de payer
l'autre point c'est aussi s'assurer que
si on met de l'argent en commun au
niveau européen on fasse pas exactement
la même chose en doublon au niveau
national ceux ci n'ont pas eu deux fois
et vous quand vous paierez vous impôts
dans quelques années ça vous serez
ambleurs à blizzard donner 1 euro pour
qui les choses qui se passent au niveau
européen et un même l'euro pour qui ce
passe d'autres choses au niveau français
donc tout l'enjeu c'est que si on
augmente le budget européen pour faire
des choses ensemble parce qu'on pense
que c'est au bon niveau que de le faire
au niveau européen parce que c'est plus
efficace mais il faut s'assurer qu'on
fasse pas en parallèle la même chose sur
la recherche spatiale par exemple c'est
un bon exemple d'une politique où ça
fait beaucoup de sens de travailler
ensemble ça rien qui ait vingt sept
fusées différentes ils sont soudain
europe ce qui compte c'est qu'on en a
une qui marche bien et qui soit
tellement bien que à force d'en produire
et coûtent de moins en moins cher c'est
un bon exemple d'une politique où il
faut qu on acte on n'accepte pas de
d'abandonner notre souveraineté mais de
se rendre compte que ça n'a pas beaucoup
de sens de faire 27 fusée pareil dans la
recherche sur le cancer
pareil sur la gestion des frontières on
a beaucoup de sujets on voit bien que
l'intérêt c'est vraiment mettre en
commun des moyens même si ça veut dire
qu'on a plus nous mêmes notre politique
de la recherche spatiale comme on
l'avait il ya 50 ans donc c'est ça qui
est difficile parce que à la fois on
aimerait des grandes politiques
européennes on aimerait ne pas augmenter
les impôts
les européens et on aimerait qu'à la fin
en plus ça fasse pas doublon avec les
politiques nationales
c'est là dessus qu'on passe nos nuits et
nos jours les prochains mois et déjà
depuis longtemps sur le budget européen
on doit se mettre d'accord sur le budget
2021 et 2027
on espère qu'on aura un accord peut-être
d'ici la fin de l'année ou au plus tard
au mois de mars l'année prochaine
elle vous déjà demandé avant on va faire
le tour derrière après puisque vous
aviez aussi une question bonjour moi je
m'appelle mélodies jeu en seconde bep
bac le lycée kastler et je voulais juste
vous demander quelles sont les décisions
communes prises contre le terrorisme
commune européenne
alors le sujet du terrorisme
ce n'est rien qui auxquels sont
confrontés des états individuels le
fondamentalisme l'extrémisme le
terrorisme ou être détruire nos valeurs
il y avait des attentats à berlin comme
à paris à strasbourg comme à 2 dans
d'autres villes de l'europe
mais jusqu'ici nos services de sécurité
ne travaillent pour la plupart
qu'individuellement la police par
exemple en allemagne relève de la
compétence des länder
nous n'avons ou bien sûr nous avons une
police fédérale mais pour la sécurité en
règle générale c'est les länder les
défendre et gyan qui s'en occupe et une
des grandes missions des dernières
années aussi dans le contexte ce fléau
du terrorisme c'était de collaborer plus
étroitement c'est-à-dire d'échanger
davantage les informations ne pas
travailler l'un contre l'autre mais de
coopérer échanges et travailler en
équipe et changer les données également
afin de trouver plus en amant les traces
d'un terroriste
c'est à dire réduire les limites les
frontières malheureusement il s'agit pas
là seulement de réduire les barrières
mais nous avons entre temps également
créer d'autres barrières il y a
malheureusement des contrôles au niveau
des frontières puisque vous et là je
suis vraiment pas pour car pendant
longtemps j'ai vécu à côté d'un mur j'ai
grandi dans un air où il y avait encore
des frontières des contrôles est là
aujourd'hui nous vivons encore une fois
ces contrôles il y a également des
hommes ou des femmes politiques qui
aimeraient les instauré pour des frais
de manière permanente
moi je suis tout à fait contre et
d'ailleurs il faudra échanger également
encore plus haut niveau des services de
renseignements des services secrets et
nous avons également en ce que nous
avons réussi à faire c'est de renforcer
de créer frontex
c'est à dire une agence qui aide les
pays les états membres qui ont une
frontière frontières extérieures de
l'europe afin qu'ils sèchent davantage
sèche mieux qui est ce qui rentre dans
l'union européenne
donc ça c'est une bonne chose pour nous
l'allemagne nous n'avons pas une telle
frontières extérieures l'espagne la
grèce la france
voilà des pays qui en ont qui donc une
telle agence et très bénéfique pour
toute l'europe
mais bien sûr la ses côtés restera
toujours à un sujet épineux juste et si
bientôt le procès des terroristes de
l'attak du novembre au bataclan et à
paris il va commencer
c'est parce que grâce à des échanges
d'informations comme les et michel route
entre les polices européennes c'est
europol et aussi les juges européens ces
oraux juste et bien ils ont réussi à
identifier dans huit pays dans huit pays
des complices des gens qui ont aidé les
terroristes à faire leur horreur à paris
donc ça c'est un bon exemple
on a des endroits où on peut partager
ses informations peut travailler
ensemble autre chose sur lequel on
travaille c'est retirer le contenu
terroristes des réseaux sociaux pour que
les messages qui appelle à faire des
actes héroïques ou alors quand les
terroristes pâle entre eux pour
organiser leur horreur si c'est sur
twitter si sur facebook ou 6 et rieur on
a travaillé au parlement européen
d'abord les ministres ont travaillé le
parlement européen travaille et on pense
qu'il faut qu'ils y retravaille un peu
on va on va voilà pour que si jamais on
identifie que la police identifie un
message terroristes et bien qu'il puisse
être
j'irai le plus vite possible pour qu'il
y ait le moins de monde possible qu'ils
le voient parce que sinon on voit
souvent que ça crée énormément de
violence et de et de victimes
et puis il ya un dernier élément c'est
tout ce qu'on peut faire aussi sur la
prévention de la radicalisation
ça veut dire aussi qu'on soit capable
d'identifier et quartiers les zones où
les idées radicales les idées théorise
prospère et ça ça veut dire mettre
beaucoup d'argent dans la formation
beaucoup d'argent dans l'éducation
ça peut paraître de la prévention
lointaine enfin ça nous semble à mon
avis assez important et donc c'est les
investissements qu'on fait pour les
prochaines générations pour que ça ne
grandissent pas plus en europe qu'en
fait vous voyez l'europe c'est
intéressant c'est un très bon exemple
c'est un sujet qui inquiète beaucoup et
sur lesquels petit à petit on est en
train de construire toute une politique
nouvelle
on a vu sur les frontières on l'a vu sur
le partage d'informations sur les
coordinations mais aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux ou sur justement la coordination
des juges au oui
et effectivement dans dans beaucoup de
domaines on travaille aussi tout
simplement à l'échelle transfrontalière
avec nos voisins
cancon cauneille avec lesquels nous
avons beaucoup de projets et nous avons
notamment dans les prochains jours une
rencontre avec nos voisins allemands et
nos services de la solidarité du
département pour confronter nos
expériences dans la prévention de la
radicalisation
parce qu'il ya des expériences qui ne
sont pas forcément les mêmes lorsqu'on
habite d'un côté ou de l'autre du rhin
est ce assez
j'ai envie de dire l'europe du quotidien
l'europe du concret qui vous tient tant
à coeur
chère amélie je le sais et d'ailleurs
pour aller encore plus loin dans ce
cadre là nous sommes en train d'initier
ici même dans cette maison au
département des binômes franco-allemand
donc des j'ai envie de dire des
partenariats entre des
agent de nos équipes du département et
des équipes allemandes du reggae aux ex
président yomou ou d'autres institutions
allemandes
oui bonjour je m'appelle tobias je suis
un course us à l'université haute alsace
j'aurai une question écrite plutôt
critique car pendant les beaux mots
d'introduction vous aviez dit voilà
c'est une chance l'europe il faudrait
s'investir ne pas le passé on a souvent
vu que c'était ainsi c'est à dire que
les jeunes se sont investis se sont
engagés mais on ne les a pas et côté
donc voilà quel est votre proposition
concrète comment peut-on s'investir
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et c'est quoi
la partie critique et ben c'était la
partie critique c'est à dire que voilà
engagé vous m'aidez lorsqu'on s'engage
dès lors ce qu'on dit quelque chose au
niveau national ou au niveau européen et
bien il n'y a pas de conséquence pas de
suite à ce qu'on dit donc c'est ça la
question comment peut-on s'investir
concrètement en europe c'est ça alors
mon impression est tout à fait
différente si je regarde toute cette
discussion autour des frais défaut
fritsch je me rappelle je me souviens de
mon passé étudiants aujourd'hui on prend
beaucoup plus au sérieux ces jeunes
on en débat lors de toutes nos
rencontres chaque mercredi
je me retrouve avec mes collègues et à
chaque fois on parle des riders of huge
de la protection du climat de ce qu'ont
dit les jeunes ce qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire encore et tout cela est toujours
lié aux discussions freedhoff youtube
entre temps il y à une myriade de
possibilités d'entrer en contact direct
avec les hommes et des femmes politiques
cette impression qu'on est très loin de
la base
eh ben c'est fou c'est pas vrai toi tu
peux m'écrire message instagram un
message sur facebook tu peux tu t'es
quelque chose et jus recevra ton message
dans une fraction de seconde et il y a
encore dix ans ce n'était pas encore
possible et si tu m'envoies un tel
message je le lis personnellement et
donc 95% des cas je réponds aussi
personnellement
bon si je lutte enfin je le fais dans 95
% des cas
bien sûr si te me donnes ton avis je
peux pas te garantir que tout sera sera
reflétée dans une législation
il faut toujours avoir de la patience si
on est active
il faut toujours avoir aussi une équipe
avec laquelle en travail il faut penser
à l'avenir il faut pas être dessus si la
première course ça ne fonctionne pas
dans une démocratie il faut avoir une
langue allen lors de tous les projets et
dans une démocratie il y a beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas été aux manettes
pendant une seule journée et qui ont
tout de même changer les choses et ça il
faut aussi le savoir mon dans les
régimes autoritaires
c'est tout à fait simple là une seule
personne a son avis est que changer tout
alors les démocraties fonctionne
différemment mais moi j'aimerais vous
lancé cet appel alors aujourd'hui vous
avez tant de possibilités vous pouvez
entrer ou devenir membre dans des
partis dans des associations comme
amnesty ou de protection du climat
il ya tant de possibilités
toute une panoplie n'êtes pourtant il
faut investir du temps ces jeux là vous
il faut investir du temps mais moi
j'écoute
bien sûr je peux pas garantir que toutes
les propositions seront repris et mis en
oeuvre tout de suite d'un homme
politique ça marchera jamais parce que
michel et moi on peut s'appeler tous les
matins on peut se dire tous les matins
on va construire l'europe
on va se mettre d'accord on va faire des
projets depuis paris et berlin
ça restera tout petit parce qu'on a que
deux tombes journée on a que deux bras
l'europe et se fait beaucoup plus par
déjà votre vie votre votre exemple vous
êtes si j'ai bien compris de nationalité
allemande et vous étudier dans une
université qui est franco allemande en
tout cas un programme franco allemand le
fait même qu avec ce diplôme qui va être
reconnue des deux côtés de la frontière
vous puissiez travailler en france
habiter en allemagne construit une
entreprise en france et embaucher des
allemands ou bien construit dans
l'entreprise en allemagne a embauché des
français ça fait beaucoup plus l'europe
au quotidien ça veut dire ça fait
beaucoup plus travaillée par delà nos
frontières des gens qui ont des
compétences et qui ont envie d'être
ensemble plutôt que chacun derrière des
frontières et se dire que ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté c'est forcément
négatif c'est un investissement beaucoup
plus fort que beaucoup beaucoup de
choses dont on discute avec michel on
citerait c'est très important
moi je dis que l'europe et se fait
beaucoup plus par des citoyens qui au
quotidien ont compris quelle était la
logique la logique c'est d'arrêter de
faire la guerre de tous contre tous
c'est considérer qu'on peut travailler
ensemble et qu'à la fin on gagne et
qu'on gagne à mettre les choses en
commun on gagne avec des moyens en
commun on gagne avec des idées en commun
on gagne à faire des choses ensemble
c'est ça l'europe si on résume c'est de
considérer qu'après s'être fait la
guerre peut-être qu'on gagnerait tous
plus à travailler ensemble et qu'un
pêcheur
oui français il faut lui donner les
règles pour qu'ils fassent pas là la
concurrence et la guerre parce que
parfois il se tueries se tuer en mer
compte le pêcheur espagnol aux comptes
le pêcheur belge parce qu'un pêcheur
belge d'arriver dans l'eau français
et qu'on se déroula tendu par lui
suivait le poisson avait pas compris qu
il était arrivé en france donc il nous
faut des règles communes et une fois
qu'on a défini des règles communes la
vie vous avez elle est révélatrice de
l'idée que l'europe elle existe comment
vous pouvez vous investir jeudi à payer
les projets et les projets de croissance
si les projets de partager les projets
d'entreprise de famille dans d'éducation
de formation
ça fera beaucoup plus l'europe que
beaucoup de discours qu'on peut faire
avec michel voyez toute la journée avec
nos micros à dire l'europe ça avance ça
avance parce que les gens comme vous qui
sont prêts à prendre des risques et
quand madame brigitte klinkert vient me
voir et me dit voyez je travaille pour
qui un train entre colmar et fribourg je
travaille pour qui les apprentis qui
soit en allemagne viennent faire leur
apprentissage en france que des
apprentis de france qu'ils aillent faire
leur apprentissage en allemagne donc
elle est professeure qui vient
d'apprendre l'allemand pour que les
personnes qui vont perdre un emploi en
france elle puisse peut-être être
embauché dans une entreprise allemande
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup plus avancer
l'europe que beaucoup beaucoup de nos
grandes directives et nos grands
discours il faut pas qu'on arrête les
directives et les discours mais il faut
qu'à la fin ça puisse devient concret et
donc je pense que le meilleur
investissement
si j'avais un conseil à vous donner
c'est de vivre une vie ambitieuse
d'avoir des projets et de les faire
grandir et si vous vivez l'état d'esprit
quel est le vôtre commun à deux pays
ben vous ferez beaucoup avancer l'europe
voilà ce qu'on crée alors on avait une
question derrière qu'attendu aussi un
petit moment
c'est bien la question maintenant
parfait bonjour je suis en hobbit mères
volontaires en service civique auprès
des jeunes européens
j'aurai une question concernant le
parlement européen
mais aujourd'hui souvent critiqués sur
strasbourg pour les coûts qu'il engendre
et alors qu'il est un symbole de
l'amitié franco allemande une
construction européenne et j'aurais
voulu savoir si vous pensiez aujourd'hui
que nous avions les moyens de le rendre
plus attrayant et plus légitime pour les
eurodéputés qui de critiquer si nous
devions le faire
des commentaires
je veux bien répondre après aussi rêvent
peut-être légiste il est tout à fait
évident que strasbourg est une ville
importante européenne et l'union
européenne a effectivement décidé qu'il
y avait beaucoup de sites beaucoup
d'endroits où l'europe devrait être
représenté par ses institutions c'est la
même chose pour mon pays les vrais que
il y à des institutions importantes
comme la cour constitutionnelle qui par
exemple ne se trouve pas à berlin il ya
d'autres institutions importantes
important de parents qui se trouve à
munich ou à cologne où il ya la banque
qui se trouve à francfort à paris et un
pardon en france n'est pas le cas c'est
vrai quand elle mène c'est un petit peu
comme en europe c'est un petit peu
répartis sur tout le territoire
pourquoi est-ce que la question de ce
sens pourrait tellement compliqué eh
bien à mon avis c'est parce que les
personnes qui travaillent à strasbourg
ne peuvent ne pas prendre la décision de
savoir s'ils peuvent continuer à
travailler a strasbourg aussi ils
doivent aussi sont obligés de travailler
à bruxelles
mais il yad'autres qui décide là dessus
et c'est pour cela que ces personnes ne
sont pas contents parce que ils ont
l'impression de pas pouvoir prendre la
décision
ils sont tout le temps en train de
voyager d'un endroit à l'autre et moi je
trouve pas ça fatigant je suis pas là
pour la plupart du temps je suis à
berlin mais apparemment il ya beaucoup
de
deux fonctionnaires de travailleurs
d'employés qui trouvent ça fatiguant de
devoir changer constamment d'un lieu à
l'autre
c'est vrai que c'est un problème un
sujet un peu critique en france c'est un
peu comme si nous on disait eh ben on va
transférer la banque centrale de
francfort berlin parce que c'est plus
facile mais pour moi strasbourg et le
coeur de l'europe vu sa position
géographique et nous le soutenons et
pourquoi strasbourg pose autant de
problèmes
pas pour moi d'ailleurs mais a vraiment
pour beaucoup de personnes qui
travaillent et apparemment ce sont
salées raison à peu près celui que je
tiens on n'est pas y'a pas washington dc
bruxelles d'ici oui on n'est pas un état
l'europe c'est pas un état il n'y a pas
de capital qui réunira tous les pouvoirs
il ya l'autorité bancaire européenne abe
l'est à paris l'autorité pour les
produits chimiques elle et alice in qui
l'aurait de la pêche et la vigo et donc
oui le parlement européen il est à
strasbourg pour ses réunions plénières
et puis pour son travail quotidien il à
bruxelles après ce que dit michel roth
il a raison c'est que ça demande du coup
des allers-retours beaucoup beaucoup de
logistique
alors j'ai rencontré klaus vélo qui est
le secrétaire général du parlement
européen et ça va pas répond totalement
la question de logistique quotidienne
bon on fait beaucoup d'investissements
quand même pour faciliter les allées
venues les séjours des députés à
strasbourg mais on va aussi utiliser le
parlement européen pendant que les
députés ne sont pas la députée
européenne une semaine par mois
il ya trois autres semaines où on a
quand même un lieu magnifique au coeur
de strasbourg où il ya aussi le conseil
de l'europe où il ya la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme il se passe plein
de choses qui pourraient être utilisés
comme un lieu notamment
vous vous demandez comment on peut être
écouté il ya beaucoup d'organisations
d'associations de la société civile qui
aimeraient avoir des lieux pour échanger
et à bruxelles on sait qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de place est donc là on
recevait le aimerait ouvrir le parlement
européen pendant les trois semaines où
les députés ne sont pas
affaire aussi vivre ce lieu comme un
lieu européens pour qu'ils les grandes
conférences pour qu'ils aient des quais
des réunions sur des thèmes importants
pour que justement ce soit lui qui soit
ouvert qu'ils soient mis à disposition
des citoyens européens
s'ils veulent faire avancer des projets
ensemble s'ils ont des initiatives
ensemble c'est que ce lieu vive aussi
quand les députés n'y sont pas qui alors
je vois leur il nous reste juste trois
minutes de trois minutes donc on va
peut-être collectionner encore deux
questions et tu es tout pour y répondre
brièvement du coup alors la jeune femme
avec le gilet orange avait déjà demandé
tout à l'heure aussi
bonjour je m'appelle claire à magendie
déjà déjà merci d'organiser ce dialogue
européen pour la jeunesse c'est super en
fait je suis étudiante en cursus
franco-allemand qui forme les futurs
enseignants bilingues et même si par
exemple la france et l'allemagne sont
des pays voisins
on remarque nouveau l'enseignement de la
façon dont les codes marche de un grand
fossé entre ces deux pays et je voulais
savoir s'il existe et si on avait déjà
eu l'idée de te créer une sorte de
coopération européenne qui viserait
voilà à faire une sorte de un pot commun
avec toutes les bonnes idées comment
pourrait fonctionner l'école au mieux et
voilà deux d'en faire une plus grande
unité du coup de rapprocher aussi du
coup les gens et donc en faire une
europe plus forte
voilà ok il ya encore une deuxième
question peut-être une réponse par
personne comme ça on va y arriver
bonjour quand à maresches terminal
abibac au lycée jeanne d'arc à mulhouse
il apparaît de plus en plus évidents des
conséquences désastreuses du typhon that
est ce que vous êtes donc prêt
à l'interdire au niveau européen et
pourquoi emmanuel macron at il renoncé à
ses engagements de campagne de
l'interdire en france
on voulait commencer
tout à fait je vais devoir vous décevoir
avec ma réponse j'en suis tout à fait
conscient nous avons tout à l'heure moi
en tout cas je soutiens le fédéralisme
et je le soutiens dans la politique et
en en allemagne on n'a même pas une
politique de l'enseignement qui serait
réglé au niveau de l'état c'est vrai que
chaque land a sa propre politique de
l'enseignement il y a entre huit ou neuf
ans pour avoir obtenir son baccalauréat
allemand et il y avait également à
d'autres niveaux scolaires il ya des
standards très différent d'un monde à
l'autre
c'est vrai qu'on s'est mis d'accord sur
des normes et des standards mais la
façon de les atteindre diffère fortement
fortement pardon d'un pays et d'un monde
à l'autre
je voudrais effectivement aussi qu'il y
ait un rapprochement en europe et il ya
une chose que nous n'avons pas encore
abordé aujourd'hui qui n'a rien à voir
d'ailleurs avec la législation et les
lois c'est d'apprendre mutuellement
c'est à dire de garder notre regard
curieux et ouvert à l'époque quand il ya
eu cette étude pisa qui a des résultats
très très négatif pour l'allemagne eh
ben on a dirigé notre regard vers la
finlande
parce que la finlande était censé être
un des meilleurs pays en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement mais on s'est posé la
question de savoir comment ils
organisent eux leur école et comment
pouvons-nous faire la même chose dans
notre pays c'est vrai que nous avons
appris un tas de choses
et lorsqu'il s'agissait d' harmoniser et
de facilité
de me marier la famille et la vie de
travail là aussi on a tiré nos
enseignements dans les autres pays et
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il faut
regarder dans d'autres pays et il se
poser la question de savoir comment l'on
peut améliorer notre enseignement et
vous en tant qu'élève en tant
qu'étudiant il vous faut également
promouvoir les échanges entre les pays
pour pouvoir nous montrer quelles sont
les bonnes voies a entamé et il est
important que ce ne soit pas l'argent
dont tu disposes les parents qui
décident sur qui peut participer à un
programme d'échangé il faut que même les
personnes les jeunes qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent puissent profiter de
ces programmes et ça c'est une autre
tâche à nous de soutenir ce genre de
programme
on va pas arriver à uniformiser notre
enseignement au niveau européen c'est un
produit qui empêche l'air de pousser et
quand on a emmené un agriculteur et
qu'on veut faire pousser une plante on
préfère que ce soit la plante qui pousse
de l'herbe qui à côté
donc c'est pour ça que le glyphosate il
est utilisé en france il utilisé entre
les cultures donc vous avez et du blé
suite la terre se repose souris intègre
qui pousse où il ya le glyphosate qui
est étendue l'herbe du coup ne pousse
plus que vous pourrez replanter quelque
chose pour que ça pousse ensuite je
précise elle ça parce que parfois on
parle de choses sans bien savoir de quoi
il s'agit en europe au départ et
quelques c'était en 2017
les européens devaient décider s'ils
réautorisé le glyphosate pour dix ou
quinze ans grâce à l'action à ce nombre
de pays l'autorisation que c'était que
cinq ans en plus emmanuel macron a dit
en france ce sera pas cinq ans sera
trois ans dès qu'on trouve une
alternative pour faire en sorte que
l'agriculteur puisse quand même à la fin
faire sa production agricole eh bien on
interdit ou en tout cas on se console
cucq dû faire en sorte que dans trois
ans dans la majorité des cas on
travaille avec l'inra autres avec les
chercheurs entre avec tous ceux qui
travaillent la terre au quotidien pour
que dans le plus de cas possible
eh bien on ait trouvé d'autres
techniques que celles que je viens de
vous expliquer à savoir deux mètres du
glyphosate entre les cultures pour que
l'herbe pousse pas partout et qu'on
puisse planter du maïs la luzerne du
colza et du blé et que donc les choses
puissent se faire donc je crois pas que
madame accroc et renoncer à son
engagement de campagne en france
aujourd'hui en france aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché
au delà de 2021 pour le glyphosate en
europe
ces cinq ans on était parti d'un point
dé pas où c'était dix ou quinze ans je
pense qu'il faut sur ces sujets-là avoir
beaucoup de précautions je préfère un
autre commentaire j'ai été à l'autorité
européenne des produits chimiques et
donc à helsinki et qui s'intéresse
savoir est ce que les produits chimiques
sont autorisés est ce qu'ils sont
interdits s'ils sont autorisés dans
quelles conditions on a droit les autres
de les utiliser et donc on sait qu'on
s'assure que les produits chimiques soit
de moins en moins utilisés dans les
façon dangereuse pour l'homme
moi je crois beaucoup à la science je
pense pouvoir toujours très attention à
ce que les décisions que prennent les
politiques ne soit pas prise parce que
on dit on pense on a peur mais parce que
on a des faits scientifiques dans le cas
du glyphosate
il ya des études qui montrent que c'est
dangereux dans certains cas
d'utilisation et des études qui montrent
que c'est dangereux au delà d'un certain
seuil les études qui montrent que c'est
dangereux tout court dans certains sur
certains produits et donc il faut qu'on
écoute la science et donc moi je fais
confiance
mais c'est un postulat je pense qu'il
faut que notre génération partage avec
nous que si on commence à faire de la
politique sur des croyances peut dire le
glyphosate c'est très bien ça produit
qui est sûrement très dangereux les
scientifiques de montre qu'il ya des cas
où c'est effectivement très dangereux et
donc plus on peut s'en libérer tant
mieux mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
sujets ou si on commence à faire prendre
des décisions sans faire confiance de la
science on risque de faire des grosses
bêtises je peux vous parler des vaccins
par exemple saviez des gens qui ont
expliqué que les vaccins ça faisait des
maladies que ça faisait des handicapés
que du coup ce qu'il fallait c'était le
plus facile des enfants c'était aussi
une croyance et les gens qui vont vous
dire c'est très bizarre où vous m'aidez
show dance donc encore qui n'est pas
naturel sauf qu'à la fin et des enfants
aujourd'hui qui meurent de maladies
qu'on m'avait éradiquer on a des gens
qui ont des enfants qui meurent de la
rougeole
ça ne s'était plus vu
des années des années et donc ce que je
veux juste dire l'art sans tout mélanger
le glyphosate et des études en europe on
a dit c'est pas plus de cinq ans la
france fait plus vite que l'europe
puisqu'elle est de trois ans et on
essaie d'accompagner les agriculteurs
pour que la fin ne met pas tous la clé
sous la porte parce que si on appelait
dans la manger produits en france avec
novembre je peux vous dire qu'on sera
obligé de manger des choses qui viennent
d'ailleurs où toutes nos normes
sanitaires s'applique pas et donc ça
qu'il faut quand même qu'on soit
toujours vigilants à ce que sous
prétexte qu'on va y avoir bonne
conscience ici on fasse pas pire
ailleurs mais si pigments sur l'exemple
des vaccins ce que ça me fait dire c'est
qu'il faut qu'on fasse confiance à nos
scientifiques
parce que si on fait pas confiance aux
scientifiques il ya beaucoup de
décisions qui auront peut-être leers
nous aurons peut-être l'air intelligente
entre quand on s'en parle entre vous et
moi sauf qu'on n'est pas scientifique et
qu'il ya des choses qu'on connaît pas et
c'est typiquement les vaccins c'est un
bel exemple de choses qu'on a d'être
pleines de bon sens mais qui ont des
conséquences très graves et donc je
pense que là aussi en europe
on travaille pour les autorités
sanitaires les eaux traitées sur les
produits chimiques les autorités
environnementales nous apporte des faits
est donc là on a un travail à faire s'il
faut que les citoyens dans leur ensemble
retrouvent confiance dans cette science
qu'on se dise pas que ces lobbys qu'on
se dise pas que c'est dicté par des
intérêts commerciaux mais qu'on fasse
confiance à la science
donc c'est juste conclure on n'a pas
renoncer à notre objectif on est en
train justement le mettre en oeuvre dans
les vignerons français seront les
premiers au monde à ne plus utiliser de
glyphosate d'ici 2021
je vais vous dire que quand vous étiez
wiener vignerons ya dix ans si on était
venu vous voir en disant il y aura plus
de viguerie faisable je pense que les
gens devraient pris pour des pour les
fadas est aujourd'hui vont travailler
autrement ils vont s'y mettre et le vent
sera sûrement meilleur qualité de
meilleure santé parce qu'il y aura moins
de produits chimiques qui auront été
utilisées pour produire
merci beaucoup pour ces derniers
répondent ces derniers question j'ai vu
il est déjà 17h28 même donc on arrive
déjà à la fin je pense qu'on a compris
il faut des hommes et femmes en
politique engagée
mais pour l'europe de demain aussi
surtout des jeunes quand vous engagez
donc investissez investissez-vous un peu
des pistes comment comment faire voilà
donc merci beaucoup d'être venu d'avoir
discuté avec nous d'être venu à voir et
avoir posé des questions finalement
assez nombreux quand même et avant qu'on
se quitte restait encore juste quelques
minutes pour une petite remise de
cadeaux pour les ministres et il y aura
un petit vin d'honneur après voilà à ne
pas manquer donc merci beaucoup et à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]